[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es ein ganz besonderes Rezept
und ein ganz besonderes Video.
Wie ihr wisst, arbeite ich ja schon seit vielen, vielen Jahren
mit der Kenwood Cooking Chef.
Schon in meiner alten Wohnung habe ich sie gerne verwendet.
Für mich ist die Kenwood Cooking Chef wirklich
eine sehr praktische und funktionale Maschine.
Ich muss allerdings aber auch dazu sagen,
Silber ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so meine Farbe.
Wir haben uns ja einmal vor 2 Jahren
- das war im September 2019 –
den Spaß erlaubt und haben die Maschine abgeklebt.
Ich habe sie dann dem Autolackierer gegebenen
und er hat sie für mich mattschwarz lackiert,
also so wie hier die Tasse oder auch unsere Töpfe.
Mattschwarz ist ja schon sehr im Trend und gefällt mir sehr gut
ist eine richtig tolle Farbe.
Deswegen bin ich auch schwarz gekleidet,
denn ich habe heute eine Ankündigung.
Es war nämlich dann auch so,
dass wir die Maschine wirklich haben mattschwarz lakieren lassen.
Ich habe sie dann auch ein paar Mal in Videos benutzt,
war eigentlich eher aus Versehen, denn ich durfte sie nicht benutzen.
Wir haben dann die Geschäftsführer von Kenwood aus UK und aus Italien
hier her eingeladen. Die haben sich alle die Maschine angeschaut.
Natürlich habe ich erst einmal einen auf den Deckel gekriegt,
weil es hieß: „Sally, wir können das doch nicht machen!
Du kannst das doch nicht zeigen! Die gibt’s doch gar nicht.“
Nach ein bisschen Bitten und Betteln war es dann wirklich so,
dass sie gesagt haben: „Okay, wir machen es für dich.“
und haben jetzt extra für mich
die Kenwood Cooking Chef Collect in Mattschwarz hergestellt.
Aber sie haben gesagt:
„Es gibt eine Bedingung. Es war ja sozusagen deine Idee
und es ist auf deinen Mist gewachsen.
Also gibt’s die Maschine auch nur bei euch.“
Das heißt, wir sind jetzt exklusiver Händler für
die neue schwarze Kenwood.
Die gibt es bei uns mit unserem Partner zusammen,
mit dem Daniel Ramershoven.
Den habt ihr auch schon in einigen Videos gesehen.
Daniel ist auch seit vielen, vielen Jahren unser treuer Partner.
Mit ihm zusammen sind wir auch schon Händler des Jahres geworden.
Deswegen bin ich da echt ganz stolz und kann heute verkünden,
dass es ab sofort schon die schwarze Kenwood Cooking Chef gibt.
Und ich habe mir gedacht, zu diesem besonderen Anlass werden wir
ein besonderes Rezept zubereiten.
Dazu fiel mir ein: Wir machen einen Black Velvet Cake.
Wie gesagt, mache ich heute einen Black Velvet Cake.
Der ist natürlich vom Red Velvet Cake inspiriert,
aber ich mache den von der Konsistenz her so,
dass er auch ein bisschen an die Sachertorte erinnert.
Lecker wird es allemal.
Ich zeige euch einmal die Zutaten.
Dafür nehme ich 100 g Oreo, 170 g weiche Butter, 100 g Puderzucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt, 7 Eigelb, 170 g Zartbitterschokolade,
7 Eiweiß, 1 Prise Salz, 120 g Zucker, 150 g Mehl, 30 g Kakao,
25 g Milch und schwarze Lebensmittelfarbpaste.
Das Erste, was ich gemacht habe, ist
den Ofen vorzuheizen auf 160°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
Heute einmal ein bisschen weniger Temperatur.
Dann nehme ich jetzt hier die Oreo-Kekse.
Die könnt ihr nämlich einfach auseinanderdrehen
- in der Werbung ist es immer einfacher. [Lacht]
Dann die Creme herausnehmen und die Kekse dann zerkleinern.
Die Creme kann ich später auch für die Tortencreme benutzen.
[Musik]
Ich zerkleinere sie hier einfach kurz in der Gewürzmühle, schön fein.
Ihr könnt sie aber auch in einen Gefrierbeutel stecken
und mit einem Ausrollstab darüber rollen.
Ihr könnt sie auch fein hacken. Ihr könnt auch einen Mörser benutzen.
Also da gibt es viele Möglichkeiten.
[Gewürzmühle]
[Musik]
Jetzt sind die Kekse gut zerkleinert.
Ich habe auch die Creme entfernt,
damit sie sich wirklich zu feinem Pulver zermahlen lassen.
Mit der Creme klappt das nicht ganz so gut,
weil die Creme einfach zu feucht ist.
Aber wie gesagt, die benutze ich gleich mit.
Jetzt könnt ihr hier nämlich die weiche Butter
in die Rührschüssel geben.
Da kommt jetzt noch die Creme dazu. Die passt jetzt gut,
weil es auch einfach nur eine Fettzuckercreme ist.
Im Prinzip ist die Oreo-Creme auch wirklich nur Fett und Zucker.
Deswegen schmeckt sie so gut.
Alle zu Hause so: „Oh!“
Aber ja, es ist tatsächlich diese Masse.
Jetzt Puderzucker und etwas Vanilleextrakt hinein.
Dann könnt ihr die Butter-Zuckermischung
in etwa 3-4 Minuten schön cremig verrühren.
[Musik und Küchenmaschine]
Jetzt ist die Zuckermasse schön schaumig
und ich gebe die Eigelbe dazu.
Immer schön ein Eigelb nach dem anderen.
Die Schokolade habe ich kurz in der Mikrowelle stehen,
damit sie schmilzt.
Ihr könnt sie aber auch über dem warmen Wasserbad schmelzen.
[Musik]
Wenn ich Schokolade oder Kuvertüre mit einbacken möchte,
dann schmelze ich sie meist in der Mikrowelle.
Da kann man sich zum einen Zeit und Arbeit sparen,
denn ich schmelze einfach nur so lange,
bis die unteren geschmolzen sind, nehme sie dann heraus
– ihr habt es ja gerade gesehen: Die oberen waren noch relativ fest.
Aber dadurch, dass sie fest sind,
schmelzen die in der übrigen Schokolade.
Dann hat man sie direkt auf Temperatur gebracht.
Da das Ganze aber nicht ganz exakt ist
und man eben nicht ganz die Temperatur bestimmen kann,
temperiere ich sie so nicht.
Aber Profis können das schon machen.
Also falls ihr Schokoladenexperte seid,
könnt ihr wirklich mit Hilfe der Mikrowelle Schokolade temperieren.
Also habe ich auch schon einmal gemacht,
aber zum Nachmachen ist natürlich das Wasserbad immer einfacher
oder mit der Kenwood
– da habt ihr nämlich eine exakte Temperatureinstellung.
So, die ist jetzt schön geschmolzen.
Die Butter-Zuckermasse ist auch perfekt.
Die Schokolade darf jetzt auch gar nicht zu heiß sein,
denn da ist ja schon Eigelb darin. Ich möchte kein Rührei.
Jetzt kann ich die Schokolade ganz langsam dazu fließen lassen.
[Küchenmaschine]
[Musik]
Diese Masse nehme ich jetzt hier kurz raus - kleiner Schüsselwechsel.
Jetzt wird nämlich noch das Eiweiß steif geschlagen.
Das kommt jetzt in eine saubere fettfreie Schüssel, mit etwas Salz.
[Musik]
Dann könnt ihr hier jetzt langsam den Zucker dazugeben
und die Masse nicht ganz steif schlagen,
sondern eher ein bisschen schlotzig.
Ich mag das Wort gar nicht,
aber zu dieser Konsistenz gleich passt es ganz gut.
[Küchenmaschine]
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier also die Schokoladenmasse.
Hier die schlotzige Eiweißmasse.
Ich zeige euch einmal, wie sie aussieht.
So, nicht ganz steif geschlagen, sondern so ein bisschen schlotzig.
Hier habe ich Kakao und Mehl und kann jetzt einfach im Wechsel
die Kakaomasse, das Eiweiß, die Oreo Kekse, die Milch
und die schwarze Farbpaste
- denn es soll ja ein Black Velvet Cake werden –
nacheinander vorsichtig unterheben.
Es gibt zwar ein Rührelement.
Damit geht es wunderbar, aber ich zeige es euch natürlich so,
wie ihr es zu Hause vielleicht auch ohne Maschine nachmachen würdet.
Bisschen Mehl, kurz unterheben.
Dann auf jeden Fall direkt eine flüssigere Masse,
also Eiweiß oder die Milch, und dann nach und nach unterheben.
Eine schöne luftige Masse soll es ergeben.
Was ihr hier vielleicht machen könnt,
damit ihr die Masse nicht so lange rühren müsst –
einfach die Farbe schon einmal in der Milch auflösen.
Dann könnt da nämlich stärker rühren.
Diese Masse soll ja nicht überrührt werden.
Da wird jetzt alles wirklich nur untergehoben.
[Musik]
So, und die Oreo-Brösel nicht vergessen.
Dann könnt ihr den Teig direkt einfüllen.
Ich habe jetzt meine Backform auf 24 cm Durchmesser eingestellt.
Wundert euch jetzt nicht über die Farbe.
Das sieht jetzt ein bisschen dunkelbraun-schwarz aus.
Ganz schwarz solltet ihr sie auch nicht färben,
denn die Farben, die ich benutze, dunkeln noch nach
und durch das Backen werden sie auch noch schwarzer.
Also deswegen nicht versuchen,
direkt die volle Farbintensität hineinzubringen.
Da kommt man echt mit sehr, sehr wenig aus.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt der Kuchen in den Backofen.
[Musik und Uhr]
Ich habe jetzt den Kuchen nach dem Backen herausgeholt,
hatte einfach eine Stäbchenprobe gemacht, ob er gar ist
und habe ihn dann etwa 30-60 Minuten
bei Raumtemperatur abkühlen lassen.
Hier immer auf so einem Abkühlgitter.
Dann kann man direkt das Blech wegziehen
und den Kuchen hier lösen.
[Musik]
Die Backfolie könnt ihr darunter wegrollen.
Und, wer möchte, kann den Kuchen noch gerne stürzen.
Dann muss ich ihn jetzt erst einmal komplett abkühlen lassen,
damit er schön kalt ist
und dann kann ich mich später um die Creme und die Deko kümmern.
Ich decke ihn jetzt einfach dafür ab, damit er auch nicht austrocknet.
[Musik]
Der Kuchen ist jetzt abgekühlt. Jetzt geht es an die Creme.
Da möchte ich natürlich auch – das soll ja ein Black Velvet Cake sein,
also wird er innen und außen und überall schwarz.
Dafür brauche ich noch einmal einige Oreo, 200 g weiche Butter,
200 g Puderzucker und 200 g Frischkäse.
Jetzt werde ich zuerst Folgendes tun:
Ich gebe die Butter mit dem Puderzucker in die Rührschüssel,
lasse es schön cremig rühren und kann die Zwischenzeit nutzen
und die Oreo wieder von der Creme befreien.
Die weiße Creme kommt hier dann wieder mit hinein
und die Kekse werden wieder fein zermahlen.
Das gibt dann eine schöne matte Kuchenoberfläche.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt hier der Frischkäse dazu.
Dann ein bisschen schwarze Farbpaste.
Ich muss sagen, wenn es jetzt kein Black Velvet Kuchen wäre,
hätte ich ihn innen wahrscheinlich weiß gelassen,
so eine Art Oreo-Kuchen - könnt ihr gern machen,
um auch so ein bisschen einen Kontrast zu haben wie hier.
So würde er normalerweise aussehen.
Aber wir wollen den jetzt wirklich schwarz,
denn die Maschine ist eine Black Beauty.
[Küchenmaschine]
[Musik]
So sieht die Buttercreme jetzt aus.
Die ist nicht ganz tiefschwarz.
Deswegen werde ich jetzt hier noch etwas flüssige Schokolade
einrühren, damit sie ein bisschen dunkler wird.
Ich habe jetzt hier auch schon die Kekse zerkleinert.
Wenn ihr diese auch tiefschwarz haben wollt,
könnt ihr ja noch Lebensmittelfarbpulver dazugeben.
Ansonsten könnt ihr sie aber auch so lassen,
denn Oreo werden schon mit einem richtig dunklen Kakao gebacken.
Aber Black Velvet – machen wir doch ein bisschen schwarz.
[Musik]
Den Kuchen schneide ich jetzt einmal durch.
Da kommt jetzt die Creme hinein.
Wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr ihn auch gern noch tränken.
Ich mache das jetzt auch mit einem Kaffee.
Ihr könnt aber z. B. auch einen Likör verwenden.
[Musik]
Es sieht ein bisschen falsch aus, muss ich sagen
- so ein schwarzer Kuchen mit einer schwarzen Creme.
Aber es wird bestimmt lecker – so wie der Black Burger.
Den fand ich auch so ein bisschen... Naja, muss man mögen.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt eine dünne Schicht darauf,
um die ganzen Krümel zu binden.
Dann kommt der Kuchen in den Kühlschrank
und ich streiche ihn dann mit der restlichen Creme glatt.
Dann ist er im Prinzip fertig, der Black Velvet.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
SALLY: Gut, können wir starten?
MURAT: Ne, warte kurz, warte kurz, warte kurz.
SALLY: Murat wird jetzt seine Schuhe anziehen, damit er größer wirkt.
MEHMET: Das Handwerk liegt nicht in der Größe.
Das Handwerk liegt in der Hand und im Kopf!
SALLY: [Lacht] Aber sag mal, trifft es bei ihm oder bei mir zu.
MURAT: Ja, ja! Okay.
MEHMET: Dir hat der liebe Gott Größe geschenkt
und das ist eine besondere Schönheit an dir!
[Sally und ihr Vater lachen]
MURAT: So. Schön mal von Papa auf Türkisch gedisst.
Das ist schon in Ordnung.
Also Papa und ich kommen gerade aus der Garage.
Wir haben gerade die Fahrräder repariert. Ja.
SALLY: Stimmt gar nicht. Papa hat sie repariert.
MURAT: Papa macht alles kaputt.
SALLY: Papa hat sie repariert.
MURAT: Schon mal mit deinem Papa zusammengearbeitet?
[Sally stimmt zu]
Ja. Weißt du, wie er ist?
SALLY: Ja?
MURAT: Er weiß alles besser.
SALLY: Natürlich. Papa weiß alles!
Also, schwarze Kenwood, schwarzer Kuchen.
Ich glaube, jeder denkt, der Kuchen wäre verbrannt.
MURAT: Der sieht verbrannt aus, Papa. [Sally stimmt zu].
Der ist verbrannt.
SALLY: Der sieht aus wie verbrannt.
MURAT: Weißt du, was das Besondere an dieser Maschine ist?
Das ist eine Weltmarke und die haben für uns,
nur für uns, eine schwarze Maschine gebaut.
Auf der ganzen Welt gibt es diese schwarze Maschine nur bei uns.
MEHMET: Großartig!
MURAT: Ich habe es Papa jetzt auf Türkisch erklärt. Genau.
SALLY: Ja, sehr gut!
MEHMET: Ich sehe zum ersten Mal einen schwarzen Kuchen.
SALLY: Aber erinnerst du dich? Wir hatten auf unserer Hochzeit auch eine.
Weiß, schwarz, weiß.
MEHMET: Stimmt, das war eine andere, aber die hier ist richtig schwarz.
SALLY: Genau, diese ist hier richtig schwarz.
Alle, die den schwarzen Kuchen gegessen hatten,
hatten schwarze Zähne bekommen.
MURAT: Ist das jetzt auch der Fall?
SALLY: Weiß ich nicht.
MURAT: Okay.
SALLY: Ich halbiere ihn einmal ganz kurz.
MURAT: Also wir hatten das wirklich.
Sally hat es gerade auf Türkisch erklärt.
Wir hatten auf unserer Hochzeit eine schwarze Torte. Richtig?
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: Genau.
SALLY: Mein Opa damals hat die schwarze Torte gegessen
und hatte ganz schwarze Zähne.
Bitte schön, Papa.
MURAT: Genau, da hatten alle Gäste plötzlich Schwarze Zähne gehabt.
MEHMET: Soll ich ihn probieren?
SALLY: Probiere gern, wenn du magst. Murat, probiere du auch.
MURAT: Papa, wenn es nicht gut schmeckt,
dann kannst du deiner Tochter schon sagen,
es hat nicht geschmeckt, gell?
MEHMET: Ja.
MURAT: Ehrlich sein, ja? Du kleiner Gauner! Papa kleiner Gauner!
MEHMET: Ich bin kein Lügner; immer die Wahrheit!
MURAT: Aber ehrlich, Papa!
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Was passiert hier gerade?
Wie schmeckt es?
Ist so Red Velvet und Sachertorte.
MEHMET: Klasse 1!
SALLY: Ja?
MURAT: Klasse 1, ja?
SALLY: Guten Appetit.
MURAT: War nichts anders zu erwarten bei seiner Tochter.
Man sucht sich ja den Mann...
MEHMET: Wirklich sehr lecker geworden!
SALLY: Ja?
MURAT: Man sucht sich ja seinen eigenen Mann aus
wie eigentlich den eigenen Vater, meistens.
SALLY: Ja, und ich wollte eigentlich einen großen Mann. [Lacht]
MURAT: Papa, dein Schwiegersohn ist größer als du.
MEHMET: Naja, so offensichtlich ist das nicht. [Alle lachen]
SALLY: Schwiegersohn hat hohe Schuhe an.
MURAT: Hat er nicht.
MEHMET: Deine Mutter hat mich damals von weitem als groß empfunden
und wenn sie näherkam, sah sie mich als klein an. [Lacht]
Damals war ich noch schlank.
[Alle lachen]
SALLY: Papa erzählt gerade, dass meine Mama gesagt hat,
als sie ihn kennengelernt hat:
Von Weitem sah er richtig groß und schlank aus.
Als sie dann näherkam, hat sie gemerkt, wie klein er war.
Das ist bei uns auch so.
MURAT: Ich, gell?
SALLY: Ja, so war es bei uns ja auch.
MURAT: Aha?
SALLY: Du hattest nämlich bei unserem ersten Treffen auch Air Max an...
MURAT: Ja, stimmt.
SALLY: ... und standest hinten an der Theke.
Ich stand dort und dachte: Ach, schöner großer Mann!
[Der Papa lacht]
Naja, jedenfalls wollte ich mit diesem Video einfach nur verkünden,
dass es ab sofort die Kenwood Cooking Chef in Schwarz gibt
und das Ganze wirklich nur bei uns, ganz exklusiv.
Daher der Black Velvet Kuchen.
Ich hoffe, euch gefällt das Rezept und das Video.
Lasst gern einen Kommentar dafür da,
ob ihr den Kuchen in Schwarz schön und gut findet,
oder ob ich auch so Team Sally seid.
Ich kann keinen schwarzen Kuchen essen und keinen schwarzen Teig.
MURAT: Das geht echt zum Beispiel auch...
Du hast doch einmal, kannst du dich erinnern,
du hast doch einmal schwarze Nudeln gemacht.
SALLY: Und schwarze Burger.
MURAT: Schwarze Burger und schwarze Nudeln essen – das geht gar nicht.
SALLY: Ja, also meine Psyche sagt einfach, das gehört nicht schwarz.
MURAT: Genau. Auch Ketchup hat es eine Zeit lang auch in Grün gegeben.
SALLY: Stimmt, das wollte keiner.
MURAT: Von Heinz – und dann wollte es keine kaufen,
weil es einfach grün war.
SALLY: Also ich würde den Kuchen noch einmal backen, auf jeden Fall,
aber ohne schwarze Farbe, denn ich finde auch,
dass die Oreo schon dunkel genug sind
und den Geschmack sowieso gut an die Torte weitergeben.
MURAT: Gut, Baba?
SALLY: Viel Spaß beim Nachbacken.
MEHMET: Sehr gut!
MURAT: Darf ich noch etwas Negatives sagen?
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: Ich fand den Kuchen fast schon zu süß.
SALLY: Echt? [Murat stimmt zu] Wahrscheinlich die Oreo.
MURAT: Fand ich echt ein bisschen zu süß, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
SALLY: Ist der Kuchen zu süß?
MEHMET: Den Geschmack hast du super gemacht.
SALLY: Ist es zu süß geworden?
MEHMET: Nein, nein! So ist er gut.
Ich weiß nicht, wie andere es sehen, aber mir schmeckt er sehr.
SALLY: Okay.
MEHMET: Ich bin ehrlich.
MURAT: Auf Deutsch: Ihm haut’s die Kukident raus. [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Er hat gesagt, ihm schmeckt es sehr gut.
MURAT: Ja, wir haben auch Untertitel.
SALLY: Ach so, okay. [Lacht]
MURAT: Könnt ihr auch lesen.
SALLY: Tschüss.
MURAT: Macht’s gut! Tschüss.
SALLY: Mama wird den Kuchen auch lieben!
[Musik]